so I have this series negative
five-thirds plus 25 over 6 minus 1 25
over 9 plus and it just keeps going on
and on and on forever so this right over
here is an infinite sum or an infinite
series and what I want you to do right
now is to pause this video and try to
express this infinite series using Sigma
notation so I'm assuming you've given a
go at it
so let's just look at each term of this
series and let's see if we can express
it with kind of an ever increasing index
so the first thing that might jump out
at you is this oscillating this
oscillating sign that's happening right
over here and whenever we see an
oscillating sign that's a pretty good
idea that we could kind of view this as
negative 1 to the N where n is our index
so for example that right over there is
negative 1 to the first power that is
this right over here this right over
here is negative 1 to the second power
that right over there is negative 1 to
the third power so it looks like the
sign is being is being defined by
raising negative 1 to the index now
let's look at the other parts of of
these terms right over here so we have 5
then we have 25 then we have 125 so
these are the powers of 5 so this right
over here is 5 to the first power this
right over here is 5 to the second power
this right over here is 5 to the third
power so this part we're raising 5 to
our index notice 1 1 2 2 3 3 and then
finally let's look at this we have 3 6 &
9 so this literally if our index here is
1 this is 3 times 1 if our index here is
2 this is 3 times 2 4 index here is 3
this is 3 times 3 so this is 3 times 1
that is 3 times 2 let me write it this
way 3 times 2 that right over there is 3
times 3 so this sets us up pretty pretty
well to write this in Sigma notation so
let's write it over here just so we can
we can compare so let me so let me give
myself some real estate to work with so
we could write this as the sum as I'll
do it in yellow as the sum so this is
our Sigma as the sum we can start our
index we can start our index n at 1 from
N equals 1 and we're going to keep going
on and on forever we just keep going on
and on forever and so it's negative 1 to
the nth power negative 1 to the N power
times 5 to the nth 5 to the N over
notice 5 to the N over 3 n over 3 n is
going to be equal to this and you can
verify when N equals 1 its negative 1 to
the nth power I'm sorry negative 1 to
the first power which is negative 1
times 5 to the first power just 5 over 3
times 1 and we can do that for each
successive term and so we're all we're
all done